President Trump is promising a mass  crackdown on undocumented immigrants  that could include families with  children he made that vow and a pair of  tweets yesterday writing that  Immigration and Customs Enforcement will  begin removing quote millions of illegal  aliens next week the details are not  clear the largest number of undocumented  migrants removed by ice in a single  fiscal year was about four hundred nine  thousand in 2012 the Pew Research Center  estimates that there are at least ten  and a half million unauthorized  immigrants in the u.s. earlier this  month acting ice director mark Morgan  said the agency plans to target migrants  with final deportation orders including  families to deter a surge of migrants  Customs and Border Protection says it  apprehended or denied entry to more than  144 thousand migrants at the southern  border last month that's more than three  every minute